sue i'm on tv i'm here to learn about
amish we're just having a good talk with
it
take care see you at the game place can
you guys
have a vehicle a car or no pennsylvania
dodge yeah
it's a german dialect i'm one of the
good players
people don't trust each other i honestly
thought nobody would talk to me
really yeah
good morning guys here in florida a
place where people come from
all over the country and all over the
world to escape
cold winter weather but there's one
group that comes here
that i think you'll find to be a bit of
a surprise
the amish i've been told there's a town
way on the other side of the state
called pinecraft
and so today we're going to go on a mega
road trip
a mission of minecraft to meet some
amish people
to understand their culture better and
to see how they live here
in florida
[Music]
okay guys we're here pinecraft and uh
wow that was an interesting shot coming
in huh
so the goal here is to talk to some
amish
but i got to be respectful i read online
that they don't like pictures
uh like still photography but if in the
background it might be okay
gotta feel it out hello
what's going on here you guys
this is the wisdom pitch the wisdom
bench
how how can i get over to the wisdom
side of things i gotta age to provide
us with wisdom i apply you with wisdom
yes
yes i'm here to learn about you guys
where are you from i'm from california
how
are you but my wife and i are staying in
miami right now
so can i sit down all right thank you
your name my name is john peter
peter i honestly thought nobody would
talk to him
really yeah i thought it would be like
taboo to talk to people because i'm not
homage but it's not like that
no no i i said something about
being one big family yeah
you can be part of that big family too
if i follow if i follow jesus right yeah
exactly like that science says you might
be surrendered to jesus
yeah you could be part of that big
family as well as excuse me jesus christ
do you find in these weird times when
being part of the family helps
oh absolutely like you have brother you
have brotherhood
you can lean on each other's shoulders
during hard times
and community we wouldn't want to do
without community absolutely
community brotherhood right do you feel
like uh
community gets threatened with all the
technology and everything or you're
strong enough where it doesn't matter
well we're bombarded with it yeah yeah
absolutely has a bearing on it it sure
does
if you want to see a lot of amish in one
spot get on the minecraft part
still here go down the street to fry
okay
turn right and go down that way so just
about the end of the street and
look left hundreds of bicycles hundreds
of bicycles and a lot of people
will they talk to me yes some will some
will
some won't it's okay if i'm walking
around with the camera and stuff sure
really
yeah i read online that it was going to
be a big problem for me honestly
now i'm saying that you're you're going
to meet an ambition now and then that
probably won't talk to you yeah i
understand
and that's just that's life that's fine
i mean we're our people are not perfect
no people are yeah but generally
speaking amish will talk to you
i'm here to learn about amish yes we're
just having a good talk with him
yeah but there's a lot of misconceptions
about amish
exactly i meet a lot of where i live i'm
a a terrorist driver and meet them all
the time from all over
yeah and uh most of them will ask me
what about this room springer
that's a german we speak german a
dialect okay
literally that means to run around the
young folks when they get their teenager
age
that we tell them okay it's okay now you
can go out and do whatever you want the
parents tell the
children that experience the world see
if that's what you want to be for the
rest of your life
well that's not true at all would you do
that with your children
go go out and do whatever you want the
uh
all kinds of uh evil things well no we
don't do that at all but the the reality
shows
and the romance books about cash okay
portray that
they think that's a seller you know yeah
it's a controversial it's a
controversial story we don't we don't
promote that
at all so what do you what do you how do
you say the word the rom
spring rom springer what is the rum
spring and then that's uh when our
youth become like 1678 before they get
married
they're in youth activities and all
things like that they're with the young
folks we say
so but some of our young people do leave
on their own okay and do whatever they
want but it's not because the
parents tell them okay it's not it's
okay to do that
tonight there's going to be a gospel
sing there by a group of
mennonites oh so they want to walk up
there
up there to the right i'm excited where
uh what time
six o'clock will you be there no i don't
i don't know no i'm going to eat fish
tonight we're about to eat fish
yeah you're eating fish hey you're like
your people
what do you call my people we call them
english just because they speak english
that's
yeah yeah we speak german all the time
at home pennsylvania dutch
you will notice how we dress yep tell me
about it
um suspenders are utilitarian they help
right
yeah yeah that holds up very long
pictures
but
that's not our dress does not get us to
heaven
no it's the heart the heart the heart
it's what it's what's in here it is but
that that's what gets you to heaven
thank you for including me at the uh the
wisdom
the wisdom chairs the wisdom table
your name john how do we do this
okay thank you john and this is the good
food
got the good food around i'm john duke
hi john nice meeting you
john ow okay john john now
thank you guys i'll see you later at the
uh the event okay
wow so that was you know sometimes you
you edit these things down where you
know don't come in any activity for like
many minutes maybe an hour maybe two
hours that was honestly right outside
the car
uh right to that so what for what a
first impression
to the amish world and my first
interaction
was meeting with those guys at the
wisdom table
so we got some food here uh they told us
about a park down here
that will have some event going on or
some some guys playing games and whatnot
and then some music event later i don't
know if we're going to do that because i
have to drive another four hours back to
miami but
let's check it out okay we have big olaf
creamery looks like some good ice cream
okay just got my ice cream at big olafs
and they're all amish ladies and a
couple guys out there
so these are one of the moments where
it's like i gotta approach it right
hopefully i get lucky
get into a vein of humanity and things
open up or i get
totally closed out so we'll see how this
goes
[Music]
hello is it okay if i sit here
yeah okay
[Music]
are you are you all from uh ohio
indiana just came out of the ice cream
shop and
got some great conversations but like i
was saying you gotta you gotta feel the
camera stuff up
out sometimes and one lady was cool she
said yes roll the camera no prom and
then
some people in front of me in front of
us
were like yeah i couldn't get the vibe
so i didn't do it got to be respectful
of this
amish began migrating to pennsylvania
in the beginning of the 18th century
from switzerland
i believe mostly from switzerland uh
because of religious persecution
hello where's the park around here
someone told me there's a park
back on pry and go that way okay thank
you
gilbert okay roughly a quarter million
amish now living in the united states
that number is increasing because they
have
a lot of kids usually five to seven
children it's pretty peaceful i like it
it's got a good energy to it you guys
are all retired
you keep active oh yeah cool
so you guys don't you guys don't watch
any tv no radios at all
we have like down here are you putting
me on tv
i'm making it so what i'm doing and you
don't have to be on any of this right i
totally respect you guys
okay i uh i have a youtube channel and i
like to show
different communities in their natural
light and give them
give them the the light that they
deserve like i was just with the hasidic
jews
in new york typically always portrayed
very poorly
i got in on some beautiful stories there
with people and this is what i do this
is what i like to do
so i like to learn from people that are
different than me you're probably just
what do you do
yeah yeah i do so i'll tell you about
the village
okay there's only one village in the
united states go ahead put me on
okay i want the people to know this
please there's only one village in
america like pinecraft
because it's peaceful
and a lot of the amish in the mennonite
used to go out to phoenix
but there's a few dopey's it's not a
safe out there
and we like to have everything safe
you know years ago we didn't have to
lock the doors but nowadays we do
here you have to lock the doors yes okay
because it's not far to the city yeah
and you know a lot of people
the virus came through here and a lot of
the older people got the bars
you know this coveted thing
was something that we were going to
experience in our life because
in 1918 they had the swine flu
but the spanish flu spanish yeah and
this one was a lot worse
yeah and you know sometimes wonder was
it god scent
or was it china some people say it came
from china
yeah but the old amish almanac says
uh-huh it's gonna be the old dutch
almanac says there's gonna be a lot of
diseases
preferring in a two-year period so
that's what we had
it's fading off it's not as bad anymore
did you have it no very little but
there's so many people
i have a brother-in-law that had bad
lungs
and he's still not recovered he's so
tired
and i have friends that had the virus
and did not recover
yeah so i can't explain where this virus
came from
from what i've felt here and i'm not
amish so i don't know
it feels like less stress yes is that
the truth because maybe less tv
no tv we have less we have stress don't
get me wrong we're just human like
anybody else
we try and take everything the way it
comes yeah
you know if something happens you know
we're trying to live with it we help
each other for
a fruit we don't believe in fear you
don't believe in fear
you can read that yeah you guys are all
hanging out very relaxed
way too much so what what's that fear
fear
people don't trust each other there's an
argentine in like
you guys you guys trust each other
pretty well amish people
within the amish we help each other we
have we have good we have bed
like anyone right we work with what we
have with the cam yeah
the cost of everything nowadays
my friend eric's got a bike and he paid
3500 for the bikes
this is a nice bike electric yeah
and now our safe now our safety has gone
down up to
950 dollars someone can steal from a
store well you've got to go and
leave what yes in fact in fact so they
can steal from a store up to 950 if the
walgreens or cvs employee says stop
or tries to stop them they get fired
now that's you know okay i want to tell
you something if you know the bible
solomon some more god let fire come down
over them and it's going to happen to us
i mean we can't live like that yeah it's
not healthy
they're letting the people steal like
that i never and that's kind of
something
it's interesting to hear that but it's
not a fun thing to hear
you know what i heard so a lot a lot of
the western
california san francisco they're moving
into the midwest
where the building is so busy there
they're moving out into the
mid west yeah out of the big cities they
say it's just
terrible the way they're building houses
so you don't have a whole lot of
confidence in your governor out there
either
no dave and news i don't have any
confidence in him he's a terrible leader
he's really bad i mean
you're exactly right it's terrible and
that's why i get into these
like the hasidic jewish community or the
amish community and i admire
the fact that you guys haven't totally
lost your minds yet you don't watch the
poisonous
uh news all day long yeah and just get
programmed by this stuff and you're
actually hanging out enjoying each other
without fear that's that's
like a really that that is a nice thing
just uh that is poisonous
it is it is hey we're on tv bob
california
bob wants in what's the problem he got
me on the team those four
are speaking for the amish in a minute
yeah one
you shaved your beard huh you shaved the
beard
i did so when you shaved the beard are
you no longer
all the men have beards you're mennonite
then oh you're men and women once
they're married
yeah once they're married okay and they
grow the beard you left
the community but you're still in the
community oh i'm in the community but
i'm just not into the average church oh
okay so you guys can all
intermingle no problem i can in our area
we all have fantastic some place it's a
someplace that's a little bit different
i'm a mennonite
i i'm i'm probably an amishman at heart
what do you mean by that i mean they're
they're part of my life okay and uh i
just
i just did not want to live
that way uh without i own my own
business i needed vehicles and i
and uh and so it was like
and today they do that a lot more
business
as an amishman then basically i would
have been able to do
when i started my business in 72. okay
so i mean
it's a lot more things changed yeah
everybody changes in life
there's always changes i mean there's a
lot of things that
amish people do today that they could
not have done
uh 40 years ago so you you 30 years can
you guys
have a vehicle a car or no yeah they do
nowadays
they it's like the magic but but do you
guys that the amish are rich working
people and the men i think
they make money so they buy the vehicles
for the man to haul them around to go to
work
and our old bishop said oh about 20
years
uh 15 years ago he said you know uh
the old the amish they want to try to
live like they did
years ago you know um
jacob almond men simmons had a split
so and
and the old bishop says we can't live
like we did 75 we can't live like that
100 like we did 100 years ago
yeah and this is what comes in bob
understands that these people
because we're in modern times if you
can't
you know see the amish in the men and
it's so just like sort of brothers
would that be we believe in the same god
and the same
uh plan of salvation uh there's
there's nothing different that we
believe from that standpoint
okay you're coming in here and you're
saying oh we're friendly and everything
but you know we have problems in our
life i mean yeah
you want to be friendly but the romans
and if you know history the antibaptist
people
and the romans we have the same problem
that they did
way back over history time yeah if you
read history
we're just human yeah but you know it's
something about the village
we have a shuffleboard tournament back
here and i'm one of the good players
you can hear that is that right and this
guy is too
he's very humble i can see that i can
see that
yeah so guys where's the shuffleboard
just down here just down here yeah
just three houses down here check it out
on the left check it out you haven't
seen it yet no i just got here i'm just
exploring
from miami this morning what's your name
junior fisher mark miller
amos bowler and this guy over here don't
say much but he's very smart
i can tell he's a smart man he's the
wise one
he's so hot noticing you were speaking
swiss german to your wife right well
it's a pennsylvania dutch yeah
pennsylvania dutch yeah which is like
it's a german dialect
okay it's a german it's an unwritten
language
if they talk slow enough by maybe maybe
you can catch a third of it
okay okay but you guys speak this at
home
yeah yes but you don't have an accent in
english
oh we can speak very we speak very good
yeah so your first language
do i have time to tell a small story
here i think my batteries are going to
hold
apparently okay now when i was in
germany
this couple uh our tour guide was a
preacher so we went to church every
night
okay and and the couple would take us
along home
overnight and they escaped when war
started they escaped four way up into
the mountains
and this is a true story they dug a hole
like this in under the ground
they lived up there for nine years and
all they had to eat was tree roots they
cooked tree roots for soup
and it's snow like it's up there every
winter and they cried when they told me
about the story
they made it a lot of people did not
make it over the war
and they made it they were older people
they were smart
so what's the california people going to
do now if everything's going away
what are they are they too poor to move
or what's going to happen
tell me the story look if it goes the
way it's going
my wife and i are moving sue i'm on tv
they got me on tv soon so so what what
are people gonna do well look it's
paradise
it really is paradise the natural beauty
of that place is paradise the climate's
paradise they've killed their killing
paradise i would say
you mean over there california just the
way it's governed
the way the politics are so what do you
think's gonna happen with america we
can't be going on like this i mean if
the
big cities are gonna start doing like
this it's it's going to be riots
everywhere
that's why i think you guys have an
advantage because you're like you're a
tight-knit community
you got all each other yeah you got you
live in safety you live in safe places
i think you've got something going yeah
that's what i would say
we got singers tonight there's going to
be a bunch of homies in a minute i heard
is it all right if i show up or not yeah
come on down six o'clock
six o'clock you're going to be there
guys
guys thank you i gotta get some signs no
that was awesome thank you so much
for your background i got some in the
house hi john
[Laughter]
thanks you guys yeah you're welcome have
a good day all right that was a surprise
i gotta say
i was told the amish are unapproachable
oh that's not true that's obviously not
true yeah
yeah right there okay take care
you too thank you the the religion is
the the guiding
i don't think that comes as a surprise
to anyone but it's the guiding
principle in the lifestyle they got
something cool going on here
take care see you at the game place
wow
hey this is what i absolutely love about
america is all the
are all these different communities
living side by side
my name is you guys everyone can exist
here
doing their own thing living how they
want
there's this this code of
or should be this code of respect each
other and
let everyone do what they want to do and
but if you're talking about the hasidic
jews
in brooklyn if you're talking about the
amish down here in florida which comes
as a surprise i think for most of us
for all the different communities
whatever you can think of they all exist
here it's such a cool thing and it's a
discovery for me this is the beauty of
it is
i'm discovering my own country i've
realized
i know nothing about the us and i'm just
starting
to learn the more of these experiences
that we can get into
the more color it adds i believe
to the country it's a very much
misunderstood uh country
yeah gotcha so they come through
i'm saying the homes are built really
well here because
of hurricanes 280 thousand dollars
and it's 800 square feet so you can see
the neighborhood is building
new construction new construction
oh wow here we go
shuffleboard at pinecraft park
another one of those feel like i'm in
another country experiences
so let's check out what the old people
are doing here
[Music]
so everyone comes out for the yodeling
at this time
ready i'm excited thank you all
see you in there and for you there's no
way you can understand it because me
even being from
it i can't understand what's going on
here guys
this is las vegas for the amish world
[Music]
seriously
you